>> LAURA: WE BRING YOU STORIES
NO ONE ELSE IS COVERING BECAUSE
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR COUNTRY.
EARLIER THIS WEEK WE TOLD YOU
ABOUT THE HUNDREDS OF MIGRANTS
WHO ENTERED OUR COUNTRY VIA THE
SOUTHERN BORDER BEING DUMPED
INTO SAN ANTONIO.
MY NEXT GUEST WENT THERE TO GET
THE REAL STORY FOR HIMSELF AND
HE IS HERE WITH EXCLUSIVE
RECORDINGS AND INFORMATION FOR
US.
YOU ASKED ONE OF THE MIGRANTS
HOW THEY GOT HERE AND THIS IS
WHAT,  SHE SAID.
WATCH.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> THEY SEEM VERY RELUCTANT TO
GIVE YOU INFORMATION VERY TELL
US ABOUT IT THAT.
>> I APPROACHED THEM ON THE
SIDEWALK AND THEN I ASKED THEM
WHERE THEY'RE FROM AND HOW THEY
CAME HERE AND THEY SAID ECUADOR.
IT TOOK A WHILE THAT THEY WERE
LITTLE BIT WARMED UP AND WHEN
THEY REALIZE THAT I WAS ASKING
ABOUT MONEY AND ABOUT WHO
BROUGHT THEM HERE THEY WERE
BACKPACKING.
THEY WERE NOT ANSWERING AT ALL.
AND WHEN I CAME BACK A FEW
MINUTES LATER AND.
>> HE SPEAKS GERMAN, FRENCH, AN
ENGLISH.
SO IT WAS EASY FOR YOU TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM AND YOU
SAID THERE ARE VERY FEW
TRANSLATORS, SO THE 30 SO URSO
PEOPLE THAT ARE OUTSIDE THE
SHELTER YOU WERE ABLE TO SPEAK
TO SOME OF THEM.
>> I THINK THERE WAS ONE OTHER
PERSON THERE WHO WORKED
OFFICIALLY.
I ASKED THEM AND THEY WOULDN'T
TELL ME ANYTHING ABOUT HOW THEY
GOT THE AIR AND THEN THEY
STARTED TO GET AGGRESSIVE AND
WE'RE CONTRADICTING EACH OTHER.
ONES THAT THEY WENT THROUGH THE
FOREST AND ANOTHER SAID THERE
WAS NO FOREST.
THEY WERE ARGUING AMONGST
THEMSELVES AND WHEN IT CAME TO
MONEY AND HEALTH THAT IS WHEN
THEY STARTED TO GET AGGRESSIVE.
>> I WANT TO PLAY SOME MORE OF
THIS.
HERE IS ONE OF THE MIGRANTS
TELLING YOU ABOUT HER JOURNEY.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> NO, THEY DON'T WANT TO TELL
YOU.
WHY THE SECRECY ABOUT HOW THEY
GOT HERE?
IT PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED BECAUSE
THERE'S BEEN ANOTHER OUTBREAK
VERY TO FAIRLY SERIOUS OF EBOLA
IN THE CONGO.
NOW THERE'S A 21 DAY INCUBATION.
, SO THE SENSE IS THEY COULD BE
BRINGING IT HERE,  BUT PEOPLE
WANT TO BE SURE SO THAT'S WHY
THE QUESTIONS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT.
>> IS, THAT MIGHT BE ONE SIDE,
BUT THE OTHER THING IS I HAD TH
IMPRESSION THAT SOMEBODY TOLD
THEM NOT TO SPEAK ABOUT THIS.
WHEN THEY SAID WE ARE HERE NOW
AND THE STATES, WHY'D YOU ASK
ABOUT OUR PAST AND THEN BECAME
VERY AGGRESSIVE COMMIT NOW WE'R
HELP, YOU HAVE TO HELP, GIVE US
MONEY.
>> WHO IS FUNDING THESE MIGRANTS
?
>> I COULDN'T GET DEEPER DOWN
THERE THAN THIS.
WHAT I FOUND OUT THEY SAID THEY
ACTUALLY DO HAVE MONEY.
QUITE A FEW OF THEM BECAUSE HE
SPOTTED THEM UNDER A TREE
COUNTING A ROLL OF MONEY WITH
HUNDRED DOLLAR BILLS.
THEY JUST PUT IT BACK IN THE
POCKET HE DIDN'T TAKE IT AWAY
FROM THEM OF COURSE,  BUT THEY
ARE STILL HANGING THERE AND
WAITING FOR PUBLIC HELP.
>> SO WHERE DID THEY EXPECT TO
BE GOING?
DO THEY HAVE FRIENDS OR FAMILY
HERE?
>> THEY ALL WANT TO GO TO FOR IT
.
>> SO THIS IS LIKE THE CONGO AN
OTHER AFRICAN COUNTRIES ARE
BEING THEY ARE REPOPULATING
PORTLAND, MAINE WITH A HUGE
CONTINGENT OF THESE IMMIGRANTS
THESE MIGRANTS.
AND ITS OVERWHELMING THAT
AUTHORITIES IN MAINE.
THEY ARE HOPING TO GO THERE.
>> THEY ARE HOPING, THEY ARE
TOLD THEY CAN'T GO THERE.
I WAS TOLD THERE IS NO SOLUTION
ANYTIME SOON FOR THEM.
>> AND YOU ALSO FOUND A DOCUMEN
THAT A GROUP CALLED HAS BEEN
HANDING OUT TO THE MIGRANTS AND
WE ARE FAMILIAR WITH THIS GROUP
BUT THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
VERY TELLING US ABOUT WHAT THIS
DOCUMENT SAYS AND PARTICULARLY
AN PARTICULARLY DISTURBING PART
OF IT.
>> SO, THEY ARE HANDING THAT
OUTBREAK IT'S IN FRENCH.
THEY ARE HANDING THAT OUT TO TH
MIGRANTS AND THEY ARE TELLING
THEM THEIR RIGHTS, AND WHEN IT
COMES TO ICE, IT SAYS ICE IS
GOVERNMENT, THEY ARE NOT YOUR
FRIENDS.
I THINK WHAT IS THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION.
YOU FLIP THE PAGE AND IT COMES
WITH ICE AND IT SAYS ICE IS KIN
OF POLICE, THEY ARE NOT FRIENDLY
, DON'T EVER TELL THEM
ANYTHING CONFIDENTIAL.
>> THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
SO THIS IS A NONGOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION ASSISTING AID
WORKERS TELLING THE MIGRANTS WH
WE'RE GOING TO GET MONEY FROM